[Music]
and tall TV news what a TV like this
instead of like this like still shorter
than Geo there's not a lot of things
like that I thought you meant like
vertical TV on the desk next level
submitted by Bao's from Joe Mallya
combined in the city of Metropolis far
traveler no angel Mallya the country of
John Mallia Cydia there's an Instagram
that combine it is called her mother
CUNY sad-ass do you got Samsung is
introducing vertical TV for Millennials
for Millennials that's the stupidest
[ __ ] idea TV like this you sounded
like a fan so it's a yeah it's a TV
sized version of IG stories like in her
living room called the Sarah which means
vertical and it's like a mirror I want
to watch my phone on my in my living
room so use that as a normal TV but uh
but yes so Oh God came out with like
other the frame supporting Samson again
but yeah so they're saying that they'll
have like airplay so you can watch
whatever is on your phone on the TV and
you can like put it horizontal and it
comes with this blue stand thingy that's
a good idea that it flips for horizontal
I just want to hate it I want to hate it
I actually do I wanted to hate it too
and I first heard about it but then I
read more into like the other features
so they're saying that this could be
used as a gigantic photo album you know
like those those electric goal or what
are they called screen savers digital
photo albums like a screen saver like
you could have your photos playing while
you have a family things that's for
later how to use it do that no
explaining the features of what I'm
saying it's a stupid house feature cuz
no one does it now and they could do it
now
I'm explaining the features that's one
of the ones that she was gonna explain
just let her go through the list dude
have to give your opinion just pop you
like it oh I love it
to tell you the rest you've got my phone
games and onion watched your TV instead
of your phone that's what I want to do
airplay feature of [ __ ] whoa because
I could do that right now yeah so you
can also use it as a music visualizer
which yes you can do to your normal TVs
now but it's just like what is it
touchscreen oh it is you you presented
it as this is you like you I want to eat
on it until I heard these things but
you've yet to say something that doesn't
exist know what I'm not trying to say
that it's something that doesn't exist
one second I'm just saying that for me
the fact that it is like you can't flip
it both ways and you could airplay
whatever's on your phone that to me is
like that's cool yes you can hell
what'll make it cool wait it's not
vertical touchscreen touchscreen is
pretty cool then we can actually play
games on it my idea didn't work and when
I figured it out of me what is it well I
was like could I just flip my normal TV
but it'd be sick was this if it really
is connected to your phone right mm-hmm
the minute you go like this the TV flips
and if you go like this the TV that
would be dope that would be [ __ ] like
if you go like this one yeah so if
you're sleeping in just like that the
[ __ ] TV just yeah versus if you're
like a seven year old grandma you're
like don't turn it off hardback you know
it's saying that's cuz you cuz the TV is
it's like a family centerpiece
everyone's gonna use it the kid's gonna
game on it the grandma's gonna watch
[ __ ] home buying similar to that it's
not at the scale of a TV but um we have
the Facebook portal and it's the same
thing it goes this way or like you can
flip it and it's pretty easy to flip
what is it
a portal yeah so they were trying to get
into like um like the the FaceTime
FaceTime thing so that's like their
version but it's it's it's that's it but
the cool thing about that is like the
camera tracks you so doesn't matter
where you're at in the room it finds
where you're at and then it just follows
you without the whole thing any zooms
into
that's the problem didn't I GTV fail
yeah that's what I was thinking well I
mean that's still around people are
doing it people are doing a lot are
using you doodle or so don't know if it
fails I sure and so yeah they're saying
that it could be used as a music
streaming hub and a handsome piece of
furniture not ugly it's a 43 inch TV
small Bubba drank the hater-aide today
smarter small sucks I know I got a
[ __ ] 65 inch TV and now I'm like she
looking out for the same fire ya see
what speakers is that week now when the
internal speakers are all asked isn't I
yeah almost any TV you have to get a
sound bar or something these days I
don't know why but they just purposely
make the sound kind of weak my whole
purpose just that you have to realize
TVs are [ __ ] this thing
yeah that's down I'm down with that Wow
yeah it's called the wall alright that's
a lower to me cuz maybe I'll get that
wait but then that what you can also go
how big is that mofo I don't know I want
a wall will it I want one wall to be an
aquarium and the other wall to be a TV
I like how you that's really basically
they never emerged the whole wall that's
really basic facing the whole tiger
walls the aquarium and the whole tire
walls a TV that the same interior design
219 int how much is that it spans more
than 15 I mean 18 feet how much is that
oh how much I've been looking at TVs for
a new house some of they get really
expensive the bigger they get I don't
know what works man but it's
exponentially though what's the biggest
you saw for example like let's say if
it's like 75 inches it could be like
like let's say 5 G's right so then this
is probably 50 G's like this okay 70
inch to 75 inch it might go from 3 G's
to vibe G's from 75 inch to
it goes up to 10 G's all set okay this
one might be 50 to 80 you're saying that
they haven't disclosed the official
price or release dates [ __ ] but only
one of you they're just teasing the
rates to put it around a hundred
thousand for 140 so I said 100 oh my god
46-inch would be a hundred thousand oh
[ __ ]
I don't watch TV enough for this who the
[ __ ] is gonna fight that dude
billionaire I get that I get if I can I
get it oh god I have a shack and that
would be it yeah so this one is that it
looked like a frame and then like all
the ports it's in a separate thing
eyelets and it only connects with one
wire and then this it has like a shelf
on top so you can use it as like the
hole this hole it's really nice for it
to be like handsome furniture they
should do it Asian it's an addition
where you can throw a vacuum cleaner
into it it won't break Asian dadada job
the Asian the asian angered dad problems
one yeah it's like bulletproof nylon
yeah I like that too the only thing is
when it turns that way I don't like the
way it looks like when it when it goes
back to your and almost TV because then
you got to put it on us think of it you
have to put it on a stand or is it the
stand is that this is this Navy thing it
comes with the TV okay so what if I
don't want maybe there you know you get
wallpaper thing quiet you could have a
spray paint bug and paint it doesn't
crack that advice
we're gonna lock the car yes you could
get bricks you can get break up he's all
wrong no argument 2,640 I know you won't
color options yeah well what if you're
an artist maybe you could get skins
maybe skins will be a whole new thing
like what about wallpaper pieces became
a whole new industry for your TV yeah
that's cool
Apple didn't even know they were gonna
set a a new industry of like protective
yeah i watch so much TV in the last like
two weeks my brain is fried like I can't
black TV know what I just because I was
thinking I was watching the game just TV
you were watching just Game of Thrones
yeah it was just like staring at that
made you know well I watch stuff now I
only put things on that I've already
seen so I don't have to look at it you
know I mean you have a whole lid yeah I
like OLED yeah I don't know between all
those so then you look at it you'll see
the difference there's like I don't like
you and it looks too real like the frame
rates too but that's just the frame rest
the family they're talking about the
quality like the resolution oh let the
colors are very fiery you know what's
crazy my TV sucks but then I put Apple
TV and it's like a brand new television
Chris you know it doesn't I don't even I
had a I had a 65 inch Samsung that I got
eight years ago that I had kept for the
longest time I think for me it doesn't
even matter at a certain point yeah is
what it is like if I could see it it
looks clean I'm fine
I don't watch enough TV to be able to
tell the color variation of like subtle
cuddle color variation I didn't know
that I couldn't do a difference either
until I plugged in the Apple TV you know
like how the [ __ ] did this little thing
make my actual TV better because that
well they have the Roku like a TC I like
the cheap ones right details are great
what do you say it looks really cheap
compared like when it's not plugged into
that ball TV cuz it looks actually like
granulated it doesn't look crisp well
the Apple TV can't can't change the
resolution of your TV those it look like
it did so the only thing that's doing
with Vizio what do you have a TCO thing
Oh see seals are nope like probably got
a car plan affordable TVs that look
really good
to actually think we got our video from
Costco yeah really good guess the only
thing I don't like is uh I think
nowadays almost all TV's are pretty good
I just don't like you when everyone lets
like they have high blood pressure it's
already ready yep
I just no change the color city those
are all settings though so like those
are all settings like you and also to
like depending on the TV that you get
some of them have more vibrant red some
of their more greens like Samsung's tend
to have more vibrant reds so that's the
high blood pressure I don't like how all
this shows film in HD now so you can see
everyone like it doesn't look it looks
to read on't like it it looks good for
sporting events and that's it oh yeah we
need to see the individual blades of
grass weird event people knew a family
like come on change the frame rate that
hurts you'll be fine that's what it does
hurt yeah most people are watching it at
120 Hertz and so if you watch sports
games it's great so you can see
everything it really hurts
but when you watch it when you watch
film you don't want to see the [ __ ] you
want to have the 24 a little bit of fun
reality yeah a little bit of blood
that's why it looks like old TV or old
film stars it looks like they were young
for so long because like their face is
so blown good now yeah Ellucian yeah
that's so good I don't give a [ __ ] about
you imagine how they felt back in the
old days when they went from candles to
electricity because oh yeah really hot
in candlelight and then there's lights
like that's true it's like your filters
always look better during the nighttime
everybody was up in anyway
[Music]